I I argue it's a depopulation agenda on
top of like all of these systems are
just to keep men and women apart you
know um and I could I could make so much
money just pandering the women I'm gonna
I'm gonna give you guys my my 30 seconds
okay my 30 seconds Pearl's just gonna
Pander to women I'll say you know you
know you just you really are not you're
really not appreciated you're not you
know and as women you know we really
just are not appreciated and we're not
valued and um we really just need to
start valuing ourselves higher and we
just have this amazing feminine energy
that men just you know honestly you have
the power women who are so special and
different and you cannot let men
convince you that you are not special do
you see how easy is it's so easy